for all those years you had to deliver
like these family-friendly lines how
would you do that it was difficult
actually there was one episode where uh
i don't remember that either but uh
john stamos apparently his character
uncle jessie uh
ran away from home and and he left the
note and i was supposed to read it and i
i couldn't get away i couldn't say the
line jesse ran away from home i couldn't
i couldn't do it without without
laughing yeah yeah yeah so um i wanted
to if i could
try to do it you yeah we have the this
is the line that you and this is true
you couldn't do this line without
laughing so this is you you go in to see
uncle jesse he's left and that note's on
the bed and you pick it up exactly and
uh so and i didn't ever say it so this
is going to be a first defeat let's see
if he can get through all right
guys
i didn't want to wake anybody up so i
left this note
i need to get away for a while
i don't know where i'm going
i don't know when i'll be back
or even if i will be back
i don't think it's working out for me
here
i'll call soon
tell the girls i love them
jesse
now i need you to be uh stephanie and dj
right i got it
they come running in stephanie i'm
hungry dj where's uncle jesse
[Music]
roger jesse
jesse ran away from home
he's a grown man no grown men don't run
away from home that's well
that's what it is yes but it was made
for kids the show yeah can i try it one
more time okay maybe i'll add my flavor
of how my comedy is now to that okay and
just how i so i'm gonna let's take it
from my line you've just finished that
just finish with tell the girls i love
them jesse all right um tell the girls i
love them
jesse okay stephanie runs in i'm hungry
dj where's uncle jesse
that greek mother jesse ran away
[Applause]
from a
you're a filthy filthy man i feel bad
that i put greek at the front of it now
i feel bad no no you don't you feel bad
you feel real bad
you